in this video you're going to learn how
to restrict the domain so that the
inverse is a function and we're going to
go through two examples together so
let's start with this first example if
we have f of x is equal to the quantity
X plus 3 squared let's just graph this
to get a sense of what this graph looks
like now we know that x squared that's a
parabola shape and the plus 3 here is
going to have the opposite effect it's
going to shift the graph left 3. so this
graph is going to look something
like this roughly okay now when you do
the vertical line test what the vertical
line test it tests to see if this graph
here is a function meaning for every x
value there's only one y value and you
can see that it passes that vertical
line test but there's something called
the horizontal line test where you take
a line like this and you scan up and
down and you see if the graph crosses
more than once and in this case you can
see that it does cross more than once
which means that it fails that
horizontal line test meaning that the
inverse is not a function so for every y
value see how there's more than one x
value
so what we're going to do is we're going
to restrict the domain now we have two
options with this problem we can either
say that we're going to look at just
this right branch of the graph this part
right here
or the left branch of the graph because
if I just look at one half of this
Parabola it would pass that horizontal
line test meaning the horizontal line
would only cross the graph at most once
so let's do this problem two different
ways so you can see both ways so here at
negative 3
if we restrict the domain and say where
X is greater than or equal to negative
three
and we find the inverse now what we're
going to do is we're going to
Interchange the X and the Y and we're
going to solve for the new y so when you
think of f of x you can think of this as
our output or our y value so we inch
interchange the input in the output or
the X and the Y
and then we solve for the new y so here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take the square root of both sides okay
the square and the square root cancel
remember when you take the square root
of both sides of the equation you get
two answers plus or minus
okay positive or negative and so now
we're down to Y plus 3 is equal to
positive or negative square root of x
and then if I subtract 3 from both sides
this comes out to let's see plus or
minus square root of x minus 3 equals y
or let's just flip it over so we can see
it from a different perspective here y
equals plus or minus the square root of
x
minus three
now going back to this original graph
here let me make this a little bit
darker see we said the domain is what
the axis can be X is greater than or
equal to negative 3. the range is what
the Y's can be and here you can see that
Y is greater than or equal to zero but
what happens when you interchange
the X and the Y the domain and the range
switch as well because the domain is
associated with the X and the range is
associated with the Y right
so what happens here is we're going to
look at this graph and when you find the
inverse you're reflecting that graph
over
the line Y is equal to X that's what
happens when you find the inverse and so
if you look at this branch of the the
right branch of this graph when I fold
it over this line Y equals X we're going
to get a graph that looks something that
looks like that okay it's just the
mirror image
now when you look at this here you say
oh okay so that means that this is y is
equal to the positive square root of x
minus 3 okay and you could write this in
the inverse notation F inverse of X
that's what this minus 1 represents
equals square root of x minus 3 and
that's this Branch right here now if we
were to do this
another way here by looking at the left
Branch okay so let's maybe draw this as
a dashed or dotted line like that
now we're saying okay let's let X be
less than or equal to negative three
when we take this Dash graph and we fold
it over the line Y equals X we're going
to get this graph right here
which this graph is the graph y is equal
to negative square root of x
minus 3.
so depending on which part of the graph
that you use you have to kind of pay
attention when you find the inverse now
what's interesting is see here I've
written this in inequality notation
let's write it in the interval notation
so the domain is going to be from
negative 3 to infinity and the range is
going to be from 0
to Infinity but what happens when we
find our our inverse graph
okay over here remember how we said the
domain and the range switch so this
range here
would really become the domain here and
that's going to be uh
where X is greater than or equal to zero
or you could say from 0 to infinity and
you can see that's what's happening
right here for for the domain now as far
as the range of this inverse function
the range would be
negative 3 to positive infinity and you
can see this is going from negative 3
and upward like that so what you can see
is that if you find the domain in the
range on the original graph by
interchanging those you'll know what the
domain and the range are on the inverse
graph and so that'll help you when
you're graphing and it'll just help you
when you're writing your notation
let's take a look at another example
okay for example number two now we have
f of x is equal to 2 times the absolute
value of x minus 1 plus 2. let's start
off by graphing this to get a sense of
what this looks like we know that this
graph is going to be going right one up
two
and so this is where the vertex of the
absolute value graph is and we know it's
being stretched vertically by a factor
of two so this is going to have kind of
like a slope of two you're going up two
over one
up two over one
and so there's our absolute value graph
okay now when we look at this we can see
that it's failing that horizontal line
test right so that tells you for a given
y value you can see there's more than
one x value which means that the inverse
is not going to be a function so what
we're going to do in order to make the
inverse a function
we're going to restrict the domain
meaning what the X values can be and so
let's take a look at this right branch
of the graph right here let's see right
here where X is one if we just go to
where it's right of one just this right
Branch let me make it a little bit
thicker a little bit wider here so we
can see it a little bit better
now when we do the horizontal line test
you can see it crosses only at most once
so that tells us that the inverse will
be a function so let's go ahead and put
our restriction here let's say when X is
greater than or equal to 1 or we'll just
say from for our domain we'll say 1 to
Infinity now the range is going to be
the Y values you can see that that's
going to be from 2 to Infinity
now let's go ahead and find the inverse
so when we find the inverse remember we
switch the X and the Y and we solve for
the new y so if I do that we get X is
equal to
now let's take a look at this line for a
moment so this this is really like a
line half of this absolute value graph
and this line you can see if I kind of
continue it
down like this okay that's our line and
so it has a slope of 2 and a y intercept
of zero so really the equation of this
line is just Y is equal to 2x plus 0 or
just y equals 2x so I'm just going to
Interchange the X and the Y
and solve for the new y so to get this y
by itself I'm going to multiply both
sides by one half
and so now we get one half X is equal to
y or if I flip it Y is equal to one half
X
or we can write it in the inverse
notation by saying F inverse of X is
equal to one half X
now remember when you find the inverse
graphically what it looks like it's a
reflection over the line Y equals X so
the line Y equals X is this 45 degree
line it has like a slope of one so I'll
try to draw it accurately here for us so
it looks something like
like that right let's label that Y
equals X and when I fold that right
Branch over that
graph it's going to look something like
this right and it's going to be the line
Y equals one half X but notice
the domain and the range are switching
so the range becomes the domain over
here so this is going to be X is greater
than or equal to 2 or you could in
interval notation you could say from 2
to infinity and the range is going to be
from 1 to Infinity so basically we're
graphing this line Y equals one half X
okay which would look like this rise one
run two rise one run two okay but we
only want the part of this line where
it's
greater than or equal to two so
basically from here onwards we just want
this part
of the line okay now looking at the
other half of the absolute value graph
the part of this graph here I've drawn
is a dashed or dotted line we're going
to look at where X is less than or equal
to one or to the left of one here so if
we do that we're going to be looking at
a domain of negative Infinity to one and
the range is still going to be
from
to positive Infinity but when you look
at this dashed or dotted line what's the
equation of that line well it has a y
intercept of four and has a slope of
negative two so our equation is really Y
is equal to negative two X plus four
to find the inverse we interchange the X
and the Y
and we solve for that new y so I'm going
to subtract 4 from both sides
and multiply everything by negative
one-half so that's going to give us
negative one half X plus two is equal to
y or we can flip it and use the inverse
notation F inverse of X is equal to
negative one half X
plus 2 and we want to keep in mind that
when we find this inverse the domain and
the range switch right so what happens
is the range actually becomes the domain
of our inverse function so we could say
x is greater than or equal to 2 or if
you're using the interval notation you
can say from 2 to infinity and our range
is going to be from negative Infinity
to 1. now graphically what that looks
like when you fold the stashed or dotted
line over the line Y equals X
is going to look like this equation
right here
negative one half X plus two now here's
the Y intercept of 2 slope of negative
one half that's down one
over two okay down one over two and
what's interesting though is we only
want to start when X is greater than or
equal to 2. so we just want this part of
the graph right
here
I should have drawn that as a dashed or
dotted line just to show you that it
matches up with this Dash or dotted line
so you can see if we were to take this
whole absolute value graph and reflect
it we would get this V shape graph on
its side and it would fail the vertical
line test meaning that you know that
this is not a function with the
horizontal line test says before you do
that if you do the horizontal line test
if it crosses more than once then
without having to graph this you can see
it's going to pass or fail the vertical
line test so it's just a shortcut
technique but here what we're talking
about is how to restrict that domain so
that the inverse is a function if you
want to see more examples follow me to
another video I did on this topic right
there and we'll get some more practice
I'll see over in that video